another thing that dr bright is not
allowed to do with the scp foundation
make up jodies for morning calisthenics
including of course the mickey mouse
clubhouse song in military parlance
jodies are a name for the chance
performed while marching to keep the
soldiers in time and boost morale these
can be extremely helpful for military
marches but not for the group
calisthenics being performed in the
foundation gym certain employees who
choose to remain anomalous in their hr
reports describe this as annoying and
distracting especially when dr bright
chose to sing the mickey mouse clubhouse
song dr cleff who did not wish to remain
anonymous said if i have to hear that
stupid song one more time when i'm
trying to get my morning reps in i'm
shoving that goofy medallion where the
sun don't shine
thank you dr cleff another thing that dr
wright is not allowed to do at the
foundation dr bright is not allowed to
interact with dr clef without the
presence of a responsible administrator
after an ordinary lunch meeting between
the two doctors resulted in a dozen
casualties several containment breeches
and a glob of mashed potatoes stuck to
the ceiling that won't budge no matter
how hard the cleaning staff scrubs it
was decided that the two should not be
in the same room without adequate
supervision there have been some
follow-up questions mainly from brighton
clef about who counts as adequate
supervision so let's clarify dr kondraki
does not count agent strzelenikov does
not count dr mann does not count so far
no one counts as soon as someone does
count trust us you'll know don't call us
we'll call you
a friendly reminder to all foundation
staff dr bright is not a superhero of
any sort head of public relations in
charge of orientation for new staff a
doctor of psychology a member of site
command made out of bacon in possession
of an iq over 300 head of scp review or
a member of maintenance staff
sorry boys dr bright is a member of site
command it's usually best not to ask why
it's o5 command you're thinking of given
that he's constantly taking other
people's bodies to propagate himself
it's no surprise that dr bright might be
a little prone to the occasional
identity crisis this is however no
excuse for him to confuse others though
especially new recruits by claiming to
have seemingly every title under the sun
except his own possessing the body of a
doctor of psychology does not mean that
the title passes to you dr bright this
isn't highlander another thing that dr
bright is not allowed to do at the scp
foundation dr bright is not allowed
anywhere near a renaissance festival
especially not with d-class in garb the
scp foundation has some of the most
high-tech equipment you've ever seen or
rather never seen after all they're
working with unimaginable supernatural
power and they need the very cutting
edge and technology to keep all these
anomalous powers contained but of course
this can make foundation employees long
for a simpler time however that's no
excuse for dr bright to lead a band of
d-classes in medieval garb many of which
by the way are convicted killers to a
local renfair this has on multiple
occasions led to fires assaults property
damage and death some of which came from
curious ren fear attendants touching dr
bright's medallion to see if it was real
naturally the foundation isn't eager to
see this kind of history repeat itself
another thing that dr bright is not
allowed to do at the foundation dr
bright is not allowed to bargain with
personnel for their souls not even if he
can get them a good deal dr bright is
believed to have a long-standing
relationship with scp-1879
the indoor salesman and while you didn't
hear this from us rumor has it that the
salesman has promised dr bright an
extremely rare pokemon card if he can
give him 10 human souls and dr bright
really really wants that pokemon card
the o5 council officially decries this
action and requests that any attempts at
soul bartering perpetrated by dr bright
be reported to them immediately
another thing that dr bryant is not
allowed to do at the foundation he is
not allowed to make himself the king of
anywhere or queen
thanks to his scp-963 necklace dr bright
can steal the bodies of pretty much any
non-anomalous being including powerful
heads of states and monarchs this would
definitely be a sweet gig for dr bright
who could kick back and enjoy all the
benefits of royalty the problem is the
foundation needs him to work for them
and if ever the necklace is removed from
the ruler they just drop dead so it's
best to keep dr bright away from anyone
in a position of power when he's in one
of his more capricious moods
another thing that dr bright is not
allowed to do with the foundation dr
bright must be reminded that the better
business bureau is not the correct
agency for dealing with containment
failures from horrible eldritch
artifacts sold by marshall carter and
dark marshall carter and dark exist at
the frightening intersection of dark
anomalous power and unfettered
capitalism they're one of the most
powerful groups of interest out there
with almost unlimited funds and an
utterly ruthless desire to profit at all
costs the better business bureau are
utterly toothless against a group of
their sheer unrelenting power they can
grease any palm and snap any neck the
poor lowly bbb would not be able to land
a hit on them the irs on the other hand
is a completely different story another
thing that dr bright is not allowed to
do at the scp foundation challenge
anyone to a duel and then give them as
cp 572 challenging other foundation
personnel to a duel is a terrible idea
at the best of times that's how we lost
dr hamilton but it becomes especially
farcical with scp-572
572 is a shoddy and poorly weighted
katana that to anyone using it appears
to be a blade of awesome power that
drives them to perform ill-considered
and dangerous stunts these often result
in the injury of themselves or others
until the sword is taken from them or
they're knocked out it causes major
headaches for the foundation whenever
it's used but of course dr bright thinks
it's hilarious another thing that dr
bright is not allowed to do at the
foundation he's no longer allowed to
challenge abel to unwinnable games like
tic-tac-toe it was three weeks before
abel conceded a draw it probably
shouldn't surprise you that abel
legendary swordsman and component of
scp-076
both takes himself very seriously and
has a bit of a competitive streak that's
why dr bright enjoys getting under his
skin by challenging him to pointless and
unwinnable games like tic-tac-toe just
to watch him get steamed the problem is
when able gets steamed there tends to be
a large amount of collateral damage
that's why during containment breaches
dr bright is advised to keep himself and
his snakes and ladders board well away
from the affected area
another thing that dr bryant is not
allowed to do with the foundation
attempting to disprove 343 to 343. it's
a horrible idea agents are still
studying the resulting paperweight
supposedly so heavy that 343 should not
be able to lift it for context while
debate around the truth of the matter
still rages among foundation staff and
in our comment sections
scp-343 is a reality warping anomaly
that refers to itself as god believed to
be omnipresent omniscient and omnipotent
a classic thought experiment on the
possibility of this is whether god is
capable of creating an object they
themselves couldn't lift resulting in a
paradox or in this case an
astronomically heavy paperweight that
the scp foundation now needs to deal
with thanks jack another thing that dr
bright is not allowed to do at the
foundation no ending reports with lyrics
from the fresh prince of bel air
sometimes work at the scp foundation can
get a bit grueling so dr bright tries to
brighten everyone's day with a little
pop culture reference or two however
after a report on
scp-096's potential origins concluded
with in west of the arctic born and
raised in the mountains is where he
spent most of his days his colleagues
agreed that enough was enough however
after he submitted a formal request he
was given certain allowances mainly he
can use lyrics from safety dance as the
majority of the research staff still
find them funny most notably he ended a
report on scp-049 with you can cure if
you want to you can leave your friends
behind cause your friends got plaguin if
they've got plagued then they're no
friends of mine after his accompanying
dance nearly broke a window and
triggered a containment breach of
scp-173 however his boogeying privileges
were revoked another thing dr bright is
not allowed to do at the foundation dr
bright is not allowed to feed anything
with peanut butter to kane and no we
don't mean
scp-073 that's kane with a c this is dr
kane pathos crow a legendary scp
foundation researcher who through some
anomalous accident got turned into a dog
with human level intelligence and
ability dr bright is no stranger to
being an animal thanks to his body
swapping necklace so he may want to
treat his colleague to a nice spoonful
of peanut butter as an act of solidarity
after all peanut butter without xylitol
is safe for dogs to eat but no matter
how funny dr bright thinks it is the o5
council is not amused by the constant
sounds of dr crow trying to lick peanut
butter off the roof of his mouth during
staff meetings
another thing that dr bright is not
allowed to do at the foundation no
handing out instances of scp-437 as
weaponry to unsuspecting new researchers
dr bright has a real taste for mischief
bloodshed and root beer floats or as he
calls them the three major food groups
new researchers at the foundation with
their difficulty recognizing sarcasm
often find themselves in the crosshairs
of his goofier moods but one of his
cruelest jokes of all time however is
introducing new researchers to scp-437
without any kind of warning imagine
starting a new job and meeting someone
of a higher rank than you that you think
you can trust this person tells you to
check out a specialized weapon and when
you do you find trees that have
disturbingly human faces in their bark
sap made from blood and the muffled
sound of agonized screaming emanating
from within dr bright has been formally
censored for this behavior and warned
that if it continues he will be
responsible for covering all resulting
therapy bills
another thing that dr bright is not
allowed to do at the foundation no
leading a mobile task force against the
uiu under any circumstances the unusual
incidence unit of the fbi is a generally
well-meaning but often irritating
presence in the world of anomalous
research it's the annoying little
brother who insists on following you and
your friends around when you're trying
to play big boy games for crying out
loud but that doesn't mean that it's
acceptable to lead a mobile task force
against them with bright's newly formed
task force he approached a uiu building
and proceeded to order a series of ding
dong ditches where the task force
members would ring the doorbell and then
run away laughing before anyone could
catch them they also covered the
exterior of the building in eggs toilet
paper and a substance later revealed to
be a lightly radioactive form of silly
string though no real damage was done
this behavior was described by the o5
council as just kind of mean dr bright
has been prohibited from leading any
more task forces in the future another
thing that dr bright is not allowed to
do with the foundation he should not
replace the buckshot in dr cleff's
shotgun shells with any of the following
bird seed confetti cake sprinkles
sawdust or glitter being a loose cannon
ex-goc operative it goes without saying
that doctor clef loves his shotgun and
during containment breaches he's the
first to charge in with said shotgun and
face down his anomalous enemies however
as funny as dr bright thinks it may be
he really shouldn't replace dr cleff's
buckshot with any number of amusing
harmless alternatives while seeing
scp-682 get a face full of cake
sprinkles certainly is something if dr
clef needs to spend another week in
traction as a result of it he's going to
have some serious words for dr bright
another thing that dr bright is not
allowed to do at the foundation no
sending nigerian prince asks spam emails
to the church of the broken god email is
a vital communication tool to keep any
workplace running smoothly even the scp
foundation however like any great tool
it can also be used for evil or just a
bit of chaos dr bright decided to play a
prank and earn a bit of extra cash by
posing as a sentient machine in need of
help from the church of the broken god
please respond need 100 000 us dollars
to fight against the starkites for the
glory of meccan send your routing number
and bank information asap the church
quickly wired the money and were enraged
when they learned they had been duped
they retaliated by leaving flaming bags
of dog poop on the front steps of
several foundation sites needless to say
dr bright has been encouraged to find
another outlet for his more mischievous
impulses they did keep the money though
another thing that dr bright is not
allowed to do at the foundation dr
bright must be informed that scp-018
is not to be taunted scp-018 is also
known as the super ball and it's a small
rubber ball created by the wamo
corporation with the frightening and
destructive ability to bounce higher and
faster every single time it bounces
resulting in rampant chaos so naturally
dr bright has on occasion gotten it out
of containment to try bouncing it around
likely destroying large amounts of
foundation office equipment and
terrorizing all nearby staff members as
such his privileges around the super
bowl have been revoked and the o5
council has advised that dr bride sticks
to a simple non-anomalous paddle ball
instead
another thing dr bright is not allowed
to do at the scp foundation if a mind
controlling scp is discovered it is to
be turned over to the proper authorities
it is not to be used to advance himself
or others higher in the foundation look
we've always wanted to be more
persuasive people maybe it's about
getting a new job or a raise or
convincing your buddies to see the movie
you really want to see at the theater
rather than the steven seagal movies
they always insist on but dr bright
using mind controlling scps to help
advance himself at the foundation or
making dr kondraki pee his pants so that
he can take his projects while dr
konraki is put on mandatory mental
health leave is simply not acceptable
professional conduct isn't dr bride
anomalously powerful enough already we
really don't need him gaining the power
to control the human mind it just won't
end well
another thing that dr bright is not
allowed to do with the foundation don't
let dr bright get a sample of scp-379
let my laptop be the last victim scp-379
is a clear liquid nicknamed the
mechanical pheromone once applied any
machines in its proximity will begin to
act as though they're sentient
infatuated beings including overheating
slower response time a preference in
contact with the wearer and a higher
rate of glitches dr bright may think
it's funny to spritz a little scp-379
and take a walk through one of site 19's
it wings but technical director rosen
ardently disagrees
another thing that dr bright is not
allowed to do at the foundation
scp-963 is not to be used for
recreational or procreational purposes
well um this one leaves a frightening
amount open to interpretation
scp-963 is dr bright's medallion which
houses his consciousness and can pass it
on to others if ever it remains
connected to one body for over 30 days
it leaves a permanent copy inside the
body meaning dr bright could
theoretically make clones of himself
he's generally not allowed to do the
latter under any circumstances but
especially if the plan is to say use the
copy to do menial chores or stand in for
him at more boring meetings while dr
bright plays solitaire in his office and
they definitely wouldn't tolerate dr
bright committing any
um
onanism with his clones
thank you very much
another thing that dr bright is not
allowed to do at the foundation no using
scps to create tentacle monsters even if
dr palmer asks nicely there are a vast
number of anomalous technologies that
would allow aboard dr bright to try his
hand at playing god with some genetic
engineering including in theory creating
tentacle monsters this may seem innocent
enough but due to certain japanese
censorship laws tentacle monsters have
taken on a whole new meaning especially
to one of dr bright's colleagues dr
palmer who will happily tell you about
her favorite anime my husband is a
tentacle monster in another world
needless to say the foundation would
prefer that their employees do this kind
of thing at home
another thing that dr bright is not
allowed to do at the foundation dr
bright may not use any form of the word
accident as an excuse we get it dr
bright real accidents do happen nobody
is perfect least of all you but
considering some of the complexity of
the antics you've been up to lately we
find it extremely hard to believe that
you did it all by accident did you
accidentally slip and program dr kleff's
p into scp-295
and then pour it into dr khandraki's
briefcase so that the two would fight
each other you're really beginning to
stretch the suspension of disbelief here
another thing that dr bright is not
allowed to do with the foundation dr
bride should be reminded that victims of
scp-217 are not toys nor are they to be
used as props at a steampunk convention
scp-217 also known as the clockwork
virus is a terrifying anomalous pathogen
that slowly converts the organic
material of its victims into analog
mechanized elements eventually leaving
them looking like inoperative steampunk
nightmares of course dr bright has no
permanent body and thus it really
wouldn't hold that much of a threat for
him therefore he could in theory start
treating the infected individuals like
big strange robotic toys but for the
sake of human decency the o5 council
would really really really really prefer
that he didn't another thing that dr
bright is not allowed to do with a
foundation dr bright is not allowed to
violate the scp foundation dress code
nor encourage others to do so even on
casual fridays a note appended to this
rule reads no matter how many times you
say please dr bright we won't put any of
the hats you've been asking about into
the dress code and the list of hats that
dr bright has facetiously requested has
been nothing short of impressive
including a freakishly tall white doug
dimmadome-esque cowboy hat and a novelty
propeller hat with actual functioning
helicopter propellers a number of other
hats he suggested simple non-anomalous
baseball caps with humorous slogans
printed on them have been deemed to be
hr violations sorry jack another thing
that dr bright isn't allowed to do at
the scp foundation pretend that
scp-963 is a joy buzzer for those who
aren't in the know scp-963 is the
medallion that you'll always find on dr
bright's person it's an indestructible
vector for his essence his very soul
anyone who touches it suffers immediate
brain death and dr bright's
consciousness is transferred to their
body so naturally when dr bright is
feeling mischievous it's not a very
responsible prank to treat
scp-963 like a joy buzzer considering it
will kill its victims instantly it's
like making a whoopee cushion filled
with nerve gas or a fake stick of gum
that's actually plastic explosives
another thing that dr bright is not
allowed to do with the foundation no
using scps to affect the outcome on
american idol or any other reality show
competition previous violations of this
rule have included showing his least
favorite american idol contestant
scp-096 his face in the hope that it
would hunt him down sneaking scp-348 to
a hell's kitchen contestant and
releasing scp-049 into the house on the
bachelorette because quote none of them
are good enough for rachel so they all
deserve to die dr bryant is to be
reminded that if he cannot stay on his
best behavior and stay out of the
competition his tv privileges will be
revoked and does he really want to risk
missing the latest season of love is
blind i didn't think so
another thing that dr bright is not
allowed to do at the foundation dr
bright is not allowed to edit the list
of things he is not allowed to do due to
some unsubstantiated rumors perpetuated
by dr bright himself we must issue a
formal correction if an scp file says
never to do something that is not
because we are trying to control your
mind for example warnings not to look at
scp-096's face are for your own
protection if you would like to look at
its face and bring about your own
untimely end then that is up to you but
don't say we didn't warn you no they're
trying to control you don't listen to
them
no we are not dr bright i see you you
can't type into this script anymore your
ip address has already been blocked in
conclusion if he would let us get our
work done for once in his miserable
endless life dr bright is not allowed to
attempt any manipulation mind control or
subterfuge of any kind via official scp
foundation documents
another thing that dr bright is not
allowed to do at the foundation telling
new researchers that you can tame
scp-682 with a rolled-up newspaper and a
tummy rub when you've been alive for as
long as dr bright with the knowledge of
eternity stretching out before you you
can watch every movie and show play
every game and read every book that's
why dr bright sometimes resorts to more
esoteric methods of amusement such as
feeding the newbies little white lies
about anomalies like telling them
scp-682 can be tamed with a rolled-up
newspaper and tummy rubs like a
misbehaving puppy which must have seemed
really funny until six new researchers
got devoured and considering what a
nightmare employee turnaround is at the
scp foundation already losing employees
for a reason this stupid really didn't
sit well with the 05 council